[Musik]
bundestag in zeiten von corona die
abgeordneten dem abstand voneinander und
beschließen in großer einigkeit das
milliarden hilfspaket der regierung
grenze zu auch für pendler tschechien
machte die übergänge dicht und trifft
damit nicht nur die grenzregion klarheit
für abiturienten alle bundesländer
wollen die prüfungen durchführen wenn
auch mit verspätung
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten um 19 uhr heute mittwoch
wieder mit einem umfassenden überblick
in sachen corona virus pandemie und da
lässt heute die einschätzung von
uno-generalsekretär görisch aufmerken
der sie als eine bedrohung für die
gesamte menschheit sieht in solchen
zeiten wächst das bedürfnis nach einem
handlungsfähigen staat auch in
deutschland weshalb heute
bundesregierung und opposition an einem
strang zogen und mit großer mehrheit ein
gewaltiges rettungspaket verabschiedeten
um finanziell möglichst vielen
betroffenen zu helfen firmen
selbstständigen mietern etwa klaus
brodbeck krone ändert alles viele sitze
im bundestag gesperrt das rednerpult
desinfiziert und der präsident dankt
zuerst jenen die draußen das land am
laufen halten
vor allem gebührt unser dank und unsere
anerkennung den ärztinnen und ärzten
pflegekräften und den gesundheits und
sicherheitsbehörden die täglich an die
grenzen ihrer belastbarkeit gehen
das parlament applaudiert den bürgern
der platz der kanzlerin merkel bleibt
den freiwilliger isolation der
vizekanzler spricht für sie
sie wissen dass sie das heute nicht
machen kann aber ich glaube auch in
ihrem namen kam ich herzlichen grüße ans
home office übermitteln
mit aller macht so die redner der
koalition wollen staat und regierung
coroner bekämpfen
dafür gibt es keinen druck gibt keinen
vorgefertigten planen den wir jetzt
einfach folgen wir werden kämpfen um
unsere gesundheit insbesondere um die
gesundheit der alten und schwachen
wir werden kämpfen und unsere
arbeitsplätze unsere
wirtschaftsstrukturen ja und wir werden
auch kämpfen um den zusammenhalt in
unserer gesellschaft die opposition
unterstützt die rettungsmaßnahmen will
sie aber früh und kritisch überprüfen
deshalb werden wir trotz aller bedenken
im detail den beschluss vorlagen der
regierung heute zustimmen
die menschen haben angst zu recht
um ihnen diese angst zu nehmen bedarf es
mehr als geld nämlich einer strategie
linke und grüne fordern bessere
bezahlung wichtige berufsgruppen etwa
medizinischen personals das kann nicht
sein dass zum beispiel pflegerinnen und
pfleger deren enorme wichtigkeit für
unsere gesellschaft uns jetzt noch jeden
tag vor augen geführt wird dass die
weiter zu hungerlöhnen arbeiten müssen
diese heldinnen und helden verdienen
natürlich den beifall auf den balkon
aber sie verdienen eben auch direkte
unterstützung und gute bezahlung gerade
in diesen zeiten eine sitzung wie keine
zuvor rettungspakete unbekannter größe
das parlament in rasender schnelligkeit
im krisenmodus corona ändert alles
das war ja schon eine außergewöhnliche
parlamentssitzung heute theo koll in
berlin
damit sollte auch ein deutliches zeichen
gesetzt werden oder
ja auf jeden fall besonders große krisen
verkleinern ja oftmals den widerspruch
und es wollte sich heute wohl auch
niemand aus der verantwortung als der
verantwortung nicht gewachsen zeigen
aber bei aller demonstrativen einigkeit
wurde dennoch auch schon deutlich
gemacht dass der staat das finanziell
nicht unbegrenzt durchhalten kann auch
die neuen rekord schulden müssen ja
irgendwann zurückgezahlt wird also bei
aller einmütigkeit heute gab es auch
warnende stimmen und die dürften in der
nächsten zeit lauter werden ja also wir
haben ja klarheit jetzt für den nächsten
wochen aber wie geht es dann weiter gibt
es schon vorstellungen wie man wieder
zur normalität zurückfinden könnte ich
glaube das ist das kommende große thema
die kanzlerin sprach ja von erst einmal
zwei wochen für die zwangspause viele
der planungen zielen auf das ende der
osterferien aber das ist natürlich ein
vollkommen künstliches datum und keines
an dass sich die viren aus breitungen
irgendeiner form hält wir dürften sehr
schnell glaube ich eine politische
debatte erleben die sich um den noch
nicht vorhandenen zeitplan der regierung
drehen wird wie lange kann man das leben
im land schließen und welchen
wirtschaftlichen preis ist die
gesellschaft bereit zu zahlen für mehr
sicherheit und gibt es alternative
modelle die die besonders gefährdeten
schützen ohne die freiheit der anderen
langfristig einzuschränken also diese
extrem schwierige debatte dürfte sehr
bald hochlaufen fragen für die nähere
zukunft von theo koll vielen dank dafür
was das hilfspaket leisten kann und ob
das geld reicht dazu mehr in einem zdf
spezial gleich direkt im anschluss an
die sendung die politik experten und
laien schauen in diesen tagen auf die
infektions statistiken von denen
schließlich stark abhängt wie es
weitergeht die amerikanische johns
hopkins universität zählt bislang 35
1740 bestätigte infektionen in
deutschland die zahl der toten ist
demnach auf 186 gestiegen das ist der
stand heute 18 uhr 30 die korona zahlen
vom robert koch institut sind ja immer
etwas niedriger aber auch aus ihnen
lässt sich für deutschland noch längst
keine entspannung herauslesen
anselm stern wie lange wird sie dauern
die virus krise die eine große frage die
weiter ohne antwort bleibt schnell
wächst die zahl der bestätigten corona
fälle
das zeigt die verlaufs kurve für
deutschland ein ende dieses wachstums
ein deutliches abflachen der kurve wäre
ein signal der hoffnung ein signal dass
die antivirus maßnahmen schon wirkung
zeigen
doch der chef des robert koch-instituts
macht klar wie sie weiter abwarten um zu
sehen ob die maßnahmen greifen
aber im moment ist es zu früh um diese
aussagen schon belastbar treffen zu
können
vor zwei tagen noch hatte lothar wieler
vorsichtigen optimismus verbreitet ist
könnte sich schon bald etwas ändern
jetzt dazu nichts mehr stattdessen
wieder diese botschaft wir sind am
anfang der epidemie
es ist noch völlig offen wie sich diese
epidemie weiter entwickelt und natürlich
steigt auch in deutschland die anzahl
der todesfälle 149 todesfälle hat das
lka offiziell bis jetzt erfasst im
schnitt sind die verstorbenen 81 jahre
alt auch hier eine warnung auch jüngere
und gesunde menschen können sehr schwer
und cupid 19 erkannt
halt nur mit einer geringeren häufigkeit
es gibt auch jüngere menschen und
gesunde menschen die an kurven 19
sterben können insgesamt 1000 patienten
in deutschland kämpfen zurzeit auf
intensivstationen gegen das virus dass
das ganze land weiter in den
ausnahmezustand versetzt
um die ausbreitung der pandemie zu
bremsen hat die bundesregierung die
einreisebestimmungen für
saisonarbeitskräfte weiter verschärft
seit 17 uhr dürfen sie überhaupt nicht
mehr nach deutschland einreisen
das betrifft zum beispiel erntehelfer
aus bulgarien rumänien oder polen etwa
für die anstehende spargelernte
derzeit fehlen vielen landwirte
arbeitskräfte helfen sollen nun
einheimische arbeitskräfte aus dem
ausland die fehlen auch in anderen
bereichen etwa in der pflege
krankenhäusern und unternehmen macht
eine entwicklung jetzt besonders sorgen
denn tschechien und polen wollen ihre
grenzen jetzt auch für berufspendler
dichtmachen polen ab dem wochenende
tschechien schon um mitternacht dann
schließt das land seine grenzen zu
sachsen und bayern fast 55.000 menschen
sind betroffen
bislang durften sie noch mit
sondergenehmigungen passieren das ist ab
mitternacht aber vorbei aus bayerisch
eisenstein berichten christiane hastrich
und barbara lueg heute mittag am
grenzübergang bayerisch eisenstein
noch läuft der pendlerverkehr zwischen
bayern und tschechien doch um 0 uhr
heute nacht ist schluss über 37.000
tschechischer pendler die in deutschland
arbeiten müssen sich dann entscheiden
für deutschland oder ihrer heimat für
die bayerische region auf der anderen
seite ist dieser schritt eine
katastrophe und trifft viele heute
eiskalt bewundern komplett überrascht
über die schnelligkeit der umsetzung und
tatsächlich ist es so durchgezogen wird
die entscheidung der tschechischen
regierung erwischt die region schwer und
stellt unternehmen aller größen und
branchen vor allem auch die
krankenhäuser jetzt vor riesige
herausforderungen
denn teilweise kommen ein drittel
manchmal sogar die hälfte der
belegschaft aus dem nachbarland
mit allen mitteln versuchen sie jetzt
die mitarbeiter in deutschland zu halten
wie hier in diesem krankenhaus im
bayerischen zwiesel was wir versucht
haben zu organisieren ist wohnraum über
den landkreis regen
das hat auch sehr gut funktioniert die
ersten wohnungen wurden schon bezogen
heute und auf der anderen seite haben
wir auch teilweise finanzielle anreize
setzen müssen um die mitarbeiter hier zu
halten
jaroslaw schock und michael creed ii
haben sich für den job und gegen die
familien tschechien entschieden die sie
nun für mindestens drei wochen
vielleicht aber auch für viel länger in
der heimat zurücklassen
ihr neues zuhause in zwiesel beziehen
sie heute nachmittag mit dicken koffern
und voller ungewissheit würde mich zu
hause eigentlich unwohl fühlen wenn ich
nicht helfen könnte also ich bin schon
sehr loyal zu meinem arbeitgeber und
wollte da vor allem den den alten und
kranken leute helfen viele unternehmen
die diese mittelständler in grafenau
aber haben nicht so viel glück
ein drittel der belegschaft pendelte
bisher täglich über die grenze von den
65 mitarbeitern aus tschechien bleiben
nur 20 und die nachtschicht von heute
reist erst gar nicht mehr an
barbara lueg ist für uns in zwiesel
barbara steckt noch mehr dahinter als
die furcht vor dem virus also für die
menschen hier in der region steckt auf
jeden fall mehr dahinter für sie ist es
im grunde ein erstes signal dass das
europa das sie bisher kannten nicht mehr
zusammen steht man muss sich vorstellen
das ist ja eine region die seit öffnung
der grenzen über drei jahrzehnte ganz
eng miteinander verschmolzen ist man
isst gemeinsam stark gewordenen mann ist
gemeinsam gewachsen
es gibt ja einen sehr regen austausch
zwischen den vereinen zwischen den
kommunen zwischen den schulen
wir haben heute mit tschechischen ärzten
gesprochen die in tschechien in ihrer
heimat leben in deutschland arbeiten und
sich am wochenende in der bayerischen
bergwacht engagieren hat es gibt ein
ganz enges zusammenspiel hier
und insofern ist dieser schritt der
tschechischen regierung nicht nur ein
wirtschaftliches desaster für diese
region sondern er ist auch verbunden
mit einer wirklich tief empfundenen
menschlichen enttäuschung
danke für ihre eindrücke von dort
barbara lueg große unsicherheit
herrschte wegen corona auch bei schülern
und lehrern gibt es noch
abschlussprüfungen was ist mit dem
abitur schleswig-holstein wollte sogar
eine radikale lösung das abi sofort auf
basis bisheriger leistungen weitere
prüfungen streichen
ungerecht kritisierten andere
bundesländer
nun haben sich alle kultusminister
schnell verständigt und auf eine klare
linie geeinigt so hat kein abitur 2020
in deutschland einen flickenteppich
während in rheinland pfalz und hessen
die prüfungen laufen trotz corona hieß
es im norden der republik in schleswig
holstein erst abwarten und verschieben
dann ausfallen lassen die verunsicherung
unter schülern war groß ich habe noch
keine ahnung ich weiß nicht wann ich
überhaupt das weitermachen kann ja auch
das überhaupt noch stattfindet aber es
ist halt schwer weil man keinen festen
punkt hat zu dem man wirklich das
abschreiben kann
mitte märz wurde der unterricht
eingestellt wann es weitergeht unklar
deswegen der vorschlag gestern aus kiel
keine prüfung trotzdem abschlüsse die
zeugnisse auf basis der bisherigen noten
erstellen heute aber der rückzug
ja ich bin vorgeprescht weil ich für
unsere schülerinnen und schüler eine
entscheidung vor freitag haben wollte
weil wir am freitag in die ferien gehen
ein alleingang der bundesweit auf
gegenwehr stieß zu voreilig nicht
abgestimmt die kollegen und kolleginnen
kultusminister irritiert abitur trotz
corona sei unter strengen
hygienevorschriften möglich die
schülerinnen schüler in hessen schreiben
im moment ihr abitur die haben heute
ihre mathematik prüfung geschrieben es
hat auch der hessischer kollege noch mal
deutlich gemacht die werden auch nächste
woche noch das abitur schreiben und wir
haben schon gesagt dass es auch ein
stückweit ungerecht ist wenn jetzt zum
beispiel prüfung komplett abgesagt
werden von einem land
abitur 2020 in deutschland die
reifeprüfungen finden statt überall
die frage ist nur wann noch gravierender
sind die folgen von corona weiterhin im
europäischen ausland denn nach italien
kommt nun auch aus spanien diese
nachricht es gibt mehr todesfälle als in
china gemeldet wurden
seit gestern starben weitere sieben 138
menschen
insgesamt zählt spanien nun mehr als
3.400 opfer am stärksten betroffen ist
die hauptstadt madrid
diese amateuraufnahmen zeigen ein völlig
überfülltes krankenhaus patienten liegen
auf den gängen und auf dem boden
unterdessen will italien verstöße gegen
die ausgangs beschränkungen deutlich
härter bestrafen wer trotz positivem
test die quarantäne auflagen verletzt
muss bis zu fünf jahren haft rechnen
und wie geht s russland mit dem virus
wie geht es dir geht russland mit dem
virus um entschuldigung
bislang wird es schlicht kleingeredet
von weniger als 700 infektionen ist die
rede aber kaum einer traut den
offiziellen zahlen was da in
wirklichkeit auf das land zukommt hat
sich heute immerhin angedeutet präsident
putin ließ sein großes projekt die
volksabstimmung über eine
verfassungsänderung verschieben und hat
erstmals selbst corona maßnahmen
verkündet für über gar berichtet
in seiner fernsehansprache verkündete
präsident putin neun tage arbeitsfrei
für alle russen und nennt das dann
verlängerte wochenende
das dient dem ziel die ausbreitung der
krankheit zu verlangsamen
lassen sie uns nicht mit der uns eigenen
russischen egal haltung an die situation
herangehen nach dem motto mich betrifft
das nicht das kann schnell jeden treffen
bislang blieb der kampf gegen korona
bürgermeistern und gouverneuren
überlassen vor allem die hauptstadt
brächte voran
moskau hat landesweit die strengsten
vorsichtsmaßnahmen hier gibt es die
meisten infizierten gestern
konfrontierte bürgermeister sobjanin den
präsidenten ungewöhnlich öffentlich mit
einer unbequemen wahrheit niemand könne
die viren situation verlässlich
einschätzen zu wenig tests zu wenig
überblick der chefarzt einer klinik die
wladimir putin nachmittags besuchte
legte nach wir müssen uns auf das
italienische szenario vorbereiten
es kann einen plötzlichen anstieg an
fallzahlen geben moskau scheint auf
diesem weg zu sein
jetzt also soll das militär sich auf den
corona kampfeinsatz vorbereiten
wirtschaftshilfen werden bereitgestellt
für unternehmen und sozial schwache
am schwierigsten dürfte das präsident
putin gefallen sein sich dazu
durchringen die volksbefragung auf
unbestimmte zeit zu verschieben
die sollte ende april stattfinden und
den verfassungsreformen einen
demokratischen anstrich verpassen
mit diesen reformen wird es präsident
putin möglich sein auch über das jahr
2024 hinaus im amt zu bleiben
präsident putin stellte die bürger
darauf ein dass weitere maßnahmen folgen
könnten
welche ließ er offen in moskau
jedenfalls wurden schon mal 1000 neue
lautsprecher montiert
auch us-präsident trump hatte in der
korona krise anfangs beschwichtigt dann
gab er den resoluten krisenmanager und
jetzt will er möglichst noch bis ostern
zur normalität zurück trotz steigender
infektionszahlen damit die wirtschaft
nicht zu sehr leidet um der zu helfen
haben sich republikaner und demokraten
nun auf 1 2 billionen also 2000
milliarden dollar paket geeinigt
elmar theveßen
mitten in der nacht ging ein signal aus
vom kapitol in washington hilfe ist auf
dem weg der deal ist gemacht endlich
lange hatten sie gestritten am ende
helfen sie nun nicht nur großen
unternehmen sondern auch den einzelnen
menschen insgesamt 2000 milliarden
dollar
die staatsschulden werden sich mehr als
verdoppelt 400 milliarden gehen als
günstige kredite an kleine firmen und
geschäfte arbeiten unter einem
bestimmten einkommen und arbeitslose
bekommen vier monate lang schecks über
1200 dollar vom staat 500 milliarden für
große konzerne zum beispiel in der
luftfahrtindustrie für bundesstaaten und
städte besonders wichtig 130 milliarden
direkthilfe für das gesundheitssystem
verabschieden dieses paket und sorgen
für die die für uns sorgen und helfen
millionen von amerikanern durch diese
finstere zeit zu bringen
es ist eine investition auf kriegs
niveau die männer und frauen des
großartigsten landes der welt werden
dass corona virus besiegen und die
zukunft zurückerobert
aber ihm geht alles nicht schnell genug
spätestens in drei wochen sieht donald
trump amerika wieder im normalzustand
ist the very special mustern ist ein
ganz besonderer tag für mich und an
diesem zeitraum denke ich an
ostersonntag volle kirchen im ganzen
land das wäre eine schöne zeit in
geldwerte vorteil
trumps befürchtet dass sich tausende von
menschen das leben nehmen wenn sie keine
arbeit mehr finden
solch eine aufrechnung von opfern halten
kritiker für zynisch und wissenschaftler
warnen vor einer schnellen aufhebung der
maßnahmen das virus hätte freie bahn
die folgen wären katastrophal und nur
noch ein hinweis in eigener sache
besonders wertvoll in dieser nie
dagewesenen krisensituation
wir haben unser online nachrichten
angebot komplett neu gestaltet in der
neuen zdf heute app verpassen sie keine
entwicklung und erfahren auf einen blick
das wichtigste zur corona krise außerdem
finden sie dort auch
interaktive und erklärende stories zu
unseren themen und natürlich wie gewohnt
jeden abend live und dann auf abruf die
heute nachrichten und auch das gab es
heute in afghanistan sind bei einem
angriff auf einen tempel der sikh
religionsgemeinschaft mindestens 25
menschen ermordet worden getötet worden
mindestens acht weitere wurden verletzt
die angreifer lieferten sich über
stunden kämpfe mit den
sicherheitskräften
sie hatten zahlreiche geiseln genommen
die meisten wurden von der armee befreit
zu dem anschlag bekannte sich die
terrorgruppe die es immer weniger
migranten kommen über das mittelmeer
auch weil die patrouillen im meer
verschärft wurden
deshalb flüchten die menschen nun über
einen anderen seeweg nach europa den
atlantik und dort vor der küste gran
canarias hat die spanische küstenwache
jetzt 37 migranten aus seenot gerettet
zur sicherheit untersuchte sie das rote
kreuz auf dass corinna virus und auch
das glück bekommt seine chance in dieser
sendung wie lotto sein
die gewinnzahlen lauten 6 11 18 21 35 49
und die superzahl 9 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 55 7
zum schluss noch schöne aussichten beim
wetter auch in den nächsten tagen bleibt
es sonnig und langsam wird es sogar
etwas wärme die einzelheiten gleich von
katja hornisse so viel von uns kleber
und das heute journal heute gegen 22 uhr
und hier ist morgen barbara hahlweg
herstellen
ich danke ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit
wünschen noch einen schönen abend und
verabschiede mich bis übernommen tschüss
[Musik]
meine damen und herren seit tagen ist es
dasselbe bild da gibt es diesen
wolkenfreien streifen von moskau bis
nach nordspanien über dem zentralen
mittelmeer dagegen dreht sich ein tief
bringt dort kräftige regenfälle mit auch
gewitter und schnee hier nach
südosteuropa und das nicht nur weit oben
in den bergen bei uns dagegen sind
wolken absolute mangelware und das
ändert sich auch in der nacht nicht da
ist es meist klar und im eisigen ostwind
sinken die temperaturen auf null grad im
rhein-main-gebiet und bis minus 8 grad
im allgäu und morgen steigen die
temperaturen in der trockenen luft auf 6
grad an den alpen und bis auf 13 grad
hier am mittelrhein dazu strahlt wieder
die sonne meist vom blauen himmel nur
über süddeutschland sind super kleine
wolkenfelder hinweg bei eisigem ostwind
die luft ist sehr trocken und deswegen
ist morgen die waldbrandgefahr durchaus
groß stufe vier von fünf es bereits
erreicht besonders hier nordosten aber
auch in teilen bayerns baden
württembergs und hessens das bleibt auch
am freitag noch so auch der samstag wird
noch ähnlich bei sonnenschein und 10 bis
18 grad dann kommt die deutlich kältere
luft am sonntag es fällt schnee regen
zum teil bis weit runter schönen abend
noch